there's something wonderfully reassuring
about studying history and it's probably
down to this it's all about facts and
dates now of course there are endless
interpretations as to why one country
went to war with another or actually
caused a revolution but no one can
dispute the facts that is unless you are
acclaimed TV historian Dan snow who
actually got a first-class honours
degree in history from Oxford but was
clearly off the day they studied World
War two when his six-year-old daughter
ran through a museum display celebrating
the Spitfire aircraft chanting boy boy
boy
concerning the pilots snow decided
history needed rewriting and told her
women had flown the aircraft in combat
defending this was some waffle about
allowing her to follow her dreams what
happens the day she discovers the truth
from a teacher or a friend why didn't he
tell her that without women many of the
planes would neither have been built nor
indeed delivered he might put the snow
in snow flake but you really wouldn't
expect this don't know much about
history attitude I have some sympathy
with downstate even though as a academic
even telly historian you rest on your
reputation and once you once you've
broadcast that you've lied to your own
daughter about something so stupid as
that you know where do you come back
from but let me just I might tell a
quick story because he wanted to his
daughter to see that women could have
daring exciting adventurous lives like
the men who were in the cockpits and
those Spitfires in the museum and very
quickly when I was about seven and my
brother Boris was about eight a son
family friend came and said to Pat us on
the head and said what do you want to do
when you grow up and so I looked up in
him and I said a wife and mother said I
knew Alexander because that was where he
was named Worthen what do you want to do
when you grow up when he went world king
let's bring you in on this because there
is undoubtedly an argument discussion to
be had about how women had been held
back and how women have advanced and you
know we might tell fibs about the tooth
fairies and Easter Bunny
yeah not father Christmas because he is
true he does exist everybody of course
yeah but you're actually would have been
better for the fellow to say look that
was then look how women have come
forward darling you can become a pilot
is that not the way to go for yeah and
and you know I know Dan very well and I
love Dan and clearly you know he was
well-intentioned and his heart was in
the right place with him doing this but
I think as a historian that he actually
should have looked in the history a
little bit more because there are lots
of amazing women who've done phenomenal
things against all the odds
why not tell you daughter about them
there are so many great women that he
could have taught what is outlying what
he should have told them was it was a
hundred and sixty-six women passing the
world with us by the back you know he
must surely know what women did they
kept this country going yeah I worked in
the fields there worked in factories
there were there were mechanics there
were electricians they they built you
you rightly said they build the place
and and actually before the war started
interesting there were only five million
women in this country who worked by 1943
Thor seven million year working and the
tragic thing is after the war and the
most bad event and me out they were the
precursor to the feminist movement
because those women tells their kids
about what they did and it's no
coincidence in the early 60s the
feminist movement started and the
biggest issue was gender inequality
that's what he should be telling these
girls great ever told any of your kids
fibs don't think of it shut down so we
should I mean is I feel this so I don't
need to be called out on a soul way
because I had to be then just condemned
by all of us really I think it is an
unwise thing to do but I think what
you've got to try and do with your
daughters is give them all the
confidence you can yeah that's the job
of a parent now give you don't tell ur
daughters they're gonna choose you've
got you've got specific
sons and a daughter yeah right I think
do you think in Britain today or the
world today because I think one of your
son are they all equally equal to get
ahead well my daughter tells a very
funny story recently of going for a job
and it was been headhunted no she wasn't
sure she was going to take it and they
said to her the guy said to her you know
why don't you why don't you ask your dad
what he thinks and she said you don't
understand my dad thinks I should have
your job boys and girls are equal in the
work placement definitely no no the data
shows you that's not good
can I back to Rachel's point and in
terms of what little girls want to be
when they grow up so this is from the
study which asked girls what they have
wanted to be and if you look majority of
girls unfortunately said artists
hairdresser there's nurse pop singer
yeah we look at that analyst of what the
boys said oh my goodness
so we have army policeman scientist
gamer mechanic the job is the women did
in the nineteen forties let's look at
what they did by nineteen forty three
eighty to ninety percent of women
working in factories on the land or an
armed forces there was six hundred and
forty fairs of women in the Armed Forces
my mom was one of them plus many more
who flew unarmed aircraft away from
these roles more than eighty thousand
women joined the women's Land Army and
worked on the farmer's land girls they
lend you a really tough conditions and
long hours an isolated rural outpost in
order to prevent Britain from being
starved out that's it that's what he
that's what he mean it's wonderful to
see that you know in the war turned
things around for women in the workplace
even though it went a bit backwards but
there are scientific journals us report
the girls as young as six which is I
think London lies dance
kinases things that there are girls jobs
and boys jobs and that they don't
validator shows at that date did you
know truly and then it and then it give
this goes right the way through the
workplace I mean today's this week's
story is about how there are own still
only 27 percent of women on boards and
that men think if they've got one women
on a board are Wiener job done
but isn't it better
prepare girls for that - how to deal
with that rather than to tell them a lie
and say there is no joke I think they
have to feel ambitious thing to believe
that the sky's the limit
I want a brig regulars we don't need to
see all doctor mr. snow said this is how
he ends it I'm bringing her my daughter
up in a way she's hopefully seeing her
gender is something that is not an
obstacle to doing anything good yeah you
think yeah we all agree with that do you
think it short telling her that but I
think the sentiment is right yeah you've
got to tell your kids but what I suspect
is still happening is this is this
happening in the middle classes unless
so in in in women are being I don't
think you're coming up the average
council estate you are being told like
your brother you can do anything whereas
I think in middle class no I totally
disagree I think actually in
working-class homes you're told you can
do anything because you have to but why
cuz you can't afford to show them - my
point is and what so in middle-class
homes you have the luxury of perhaps not
working if you don't want to
working-class women have had to work my
mom had to work her whole life we
couldn't afford you can't believe the
latter women could do anything coming
from that environment because life has
shown them they can't do anything that
there are limitations they're taught to
be grateful for but they are not brought
up to think that they're less than men
the idea is nobody can do well if you're
from that sort of people when everybody
has to work I do think I mean just from
my own experience of watching my keep my
toes of the grub knows I do think they
suddenly become aware they they going
for a career there are certain then
suddenly they realize in their 30s hang
on what do i do do I now have kids or
don't I what do I do about it and I
don't I don't think it's any doubt that
if you start it as a woman if you now
say I'm gonna have a couple of kids you
probably lose three or four years they
look good in